so you can see on the front of this
instrument there's a dome-shaped device
that dome is a special vessel which is
made so we can control the atmosphere
inside and it's fabricated from
beryllium metal this is the beryllium
which that when you want to get out its
got because it calls well because it's a
toxic chemical toxic and metal beryllium
is an interesting element because most
chemists don't really know about it very
much at all
so beryllium is a fantastic metal it's
really really interesting it's got lots
of really quite strange metallic
properties but one of the most important
for me it's the fact that it's
transparent to x-rays so I can shine
x-rays straight through the beryllium
and the brilliant doesn't absorb it at
all which most other metals especially
those with higher molecular weights do
but brilliant latent dust actually has
been shown to cause brilliance which is
actually a and industrial lung disease
which causes the formation of sort of
sort of swollen sort of nodules in the
lone that's called granulomas which is a
bit gross so I don't really want to open
up the jar it's near the beginning of
the periodic table but we rarely come
across it so so at the moment we're at
Mac's lab and we're doing some x-ray
experiments and we're doing some x-ray
experiments on a really really quite
sensitive compound so x-rays themselves
are absorbed by everything okay so when
we shoot it through the air it's
absorbed in the air so to measure the
x-ray absorption of our compound which
is sensitive to the air we need to be
able to remove the air and encase it so
we use beryllium to make a magic box
around our sample that the x-rays can
come in to interact with our sample and
then exit without interacting with the
material around them so you can see on
the front of this instrument there's a
dome shaped device that dome is a
special vessel which is made so we can
control the atmosphere inside and it's
fabricated from beryllium metal I talked
about in my lectures I explained that
beryllium chloride the molecule that has
three atoms two chlorine atoms and one
beryllium atom has the three atoms
arranged in the row so it's a straight
molecule so-called linear molecule I
never seen beryllium chloride back
chemists use it in x-ray diffractometer
because actually it's so lightweight
actually only got a tiny number for the
beryllium allows the elect the x-rays to
come in and out without interacting at
all it's a fantastic device it's really
useful for really sensitive chemistry
it's a really beautiful application the
cost of that beryllium no that's
significant
that small beryllium sample cost fifteen
thousand euros it only has four protons
and a number of neutrons so if x-rays
fall on atoms of beryllium they're not
scattered very much so it's like the
difference between shining light through
a glass window and if you made it out of
a heavier material be like shining
through paper it would be scattered you
wouldn't get a good image I'm hoping to
actually do some chemistry with
brilliant which is why I've bought it
yeah it's pretty toxic so I'm going to
have to be very very careful you can't
actually breathe in the dust at all
because even actually one exposure has
shown that some people will tell people
one exposure is enough to cause this
sort of sensitive reaction but beryllium
is very poisonous so if you do use the
these beryllium windows you have to be
careful not to lick your fingers
well good chemists shouldn't lick their
fingers anyway